NASA astronaut Christina Koch is about
to make history for the second time this
year
tomorrow will be her 280 ninth sec you
t'v day in space breaking peggy whitson
Szold record for the longest single
space flight by a woman in october cook
took part in the first all-female
spacewalk she and fellow astronaut
Jessica Muir replaced a faulty battery
unit Christina cook joins us from the
International Space Station good morning
to you good morning and welcome on board
yeah good to be with you well first and
foremost you know tomorrow you're
expected to break peggy whitson x'
record for the longest single space
flight by a female astronaut what is
that like for you what does this
experience been like well first and
foremost it's a huge honor Peggy is a
heroine of mine who's also been kind
enough to mentor me through the years
and so it's a reminder to give back into
mentor when I get back you know I also
like to think of it as it's not so many
so much how many days you're up here but
what you do with each of those days so
that reminds me to bring my best to
every single day I think it's wonderful
for science it helps us push the
boundaries of what we know about what
long-duration spaceflight can do to the
human body and that's important for our
future exploration deeper into going to
Mars and also returning to the moon and
going there to stay but overall I'd have
to say that my number one hope for this
milestone is that the record has
exceeded again as soon as possible
because that means that we're continuing
to push the boundaries pushing
boundaries is becoming the norm for you
right now back in October you and
Jessica Muir had that first all-female
spacewalk and you both wrote so
beautifully about it and in talking
about it why do you think we're seeing
these milestones now for women in space
you know I think it's a wonderful time
for human space play because I think we
finally recognize that it's not worth
going unless we go together that it's
important to not turn away any
innovative idea that everyone has a role
and everyone has a place at the table as
we move forward if we're gonna go for
all humanity and to support humanity's
love for exploration then we have to do
it with all humanity and I think we're
seeing that as our plans unfold for
going back to the moon seeing the
women walk on the moon in 2024 and just
recognizing that we have to go together
if we're gonna go and we're gonna do it
right you know Christina I love how you
say you go for all of humanity which has
sort of been the mission of astronauts
but NASA says that that's all female
spacewalk was not even intentionally
planned given its historic nature but
how do you feel about all the attention
that has been given to breaking all
those barriers you know that's exactly
right I think that the first all-female
spacewalk was more a result of where
we've decided to go my class was trained
right in step we were all trained
together and we're the first class
that's half female and half male and
class of astronauts and we were never
held to any different standards or
expectations and that was the beauty of
it you know to me it's an opportunity to
inspire and I think that highlighting
the fact that it was the first
all-female EB a spacewalk is important
because seeing those milestones be
broken sort of tells people where we're
at and where we think that the
importance lies I think that it's
inspiring because future space explorers
do need to see people that remind them
of themselves and they see a piece of
themselves in to kind of bring that
inspiration home I know that was
certainly true for me in my background
so to have the opportunity to do that
for future space explorers is a real
honor and Cristina obviously you're
there to do science but you've also
become well known for the pictures the
photography that you taken what's the
most memorable thing that you've seen
since you've been up there so many
things come to mind it was wonderful to
see the places where I grew up from
space for the first time but I would say
the most awe-inspiring thing that I've
ever seen is the Northern Lights or
Southern Lights or Aurora's we call them
from above on a planetary scale I've had
the opportunity working in Antarctica
and the Arctic to see them from below
and the beautiful shimmering lights
along the sky and taking over the whole
sky but to look down on the earth and
see the entire shape of the Aurora's you
know as they form near the poles was
truly an amazing sight and just
literally took my breath away
Cristina Cooke thank you so much for
your time it's been amazing just seeing
you up there and congratulations thank
you so much it's been my pleasure to
be with you all
you